[Music]
mad flavor here the Lord's Day
[ __ ] greetings as far as today's
concerning I'm the man of many reasons I
got the perennial og always killing
[ __ ] I got some tighten up G
from [ __ ] button roses and I got some
[ __ ] pure cush from bottom roses this
Titanic og is like twenty eight twenty
nine [ __ ] percent get you out there
to a different [ __ ] planet how are
you I'm seconds dude it's great to see
we got a podcast in minus seven someone
to start out the day smoke with you
[ __ ] just to let you know what type
of day it's gonna [ __ ] be insane
tonight we got the season finale of the
night of an HBO
my man knives more [ __ ] Arabs gonna
stab some [ __ ] tonight that's
the end of that one also had this sativa
[ __ ] tremendous I smoked it this
morning at [ __ ] 805 let's put this
away that's more to the [ __ ] death
from butter roses I just sent out a
[ __ ] Julie Rose [ __ ] it's the
Lord's Day otherwise he'll [ __ ] around I
don't give a [ __ ] what happens on the
other sixth day but on the seventh day
God created Black Sabbath he's gonna
sell we [ __ ] do it
understand me smoke some of this [ __ ]
death go inside I got a back a little
bit my main [ __ ] armenian birds
coming over we're gonna move some [ __ ] I
gotta go see a man about a [ __ ] dog I
got a podcast tonight nice [ __ ] guest
and tonight I got 11 o'clock at the
[ __ ] calm nice pool you think you
gotta run it's some [ __ ] boy
today can you imagine my [ __ ] week is
like Monday to Friday 150 I don't give a
[ __ ] jack
I got the lot of a [ __ ] ten-year-old
right now swinging bacon given our
[ __ ] bazooka bubble boom
give a [ __ ] everybody thinks that you
know I only work five days a week that's
great that's why you have the [ __ ]
shape your and once you get it to you
that there's a seven-day [ __ ]
everyday you either doing one thing or
you're doing the [ __ ] other
[ __ ] oh yeah to be like but
[ __ ] relax what [ __ ] relax relax
when you're dead that's why they put you
underneath your son no [ __ ] Bobby
look at I just [ __ ] hit a moth with
that [ __ ] breath of death and weed
and [ __ ] [ __ ] god knows what's gonna
happen to poor [ __ ] menthe
I love you [ __ ] it's great to see
you
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you got none to be depressed about
you're alive you're two feet around the
[ __ ] ground and if you play your
cards right eventually something sucking
thing you don't say I'm at the ice house
Wednesday night
but my flap is [ __ ] September 8 time
at The Improv the night in the tent on
Melrose come on guys I'm trying to
[ __ ] work as hard as I can to make you
[ __ ] proud of me uncle Joey's on this
special both [ __ ] smooth and you
could say you know what that's my
[ __ ] [ __ ] right there never
madam buddy is my uncle on paper
remember we don't have to be blunt
that's all for these [ __ ] Gentiles
that's my second cousin you'll meet new
a [ __ ] crime together we smoke a bowl
together we cry out one another's
shoulders were [ __ ] brothers brother
that's how it is I'm sorry to [ __ ]
tell you whether you're black Arab Jew
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you want
mean you do something we get together
you let's get this company I know help
me move this [ __ ] Armenian Savage if
you don't have an Armenian as a friends
your life Fame or two Dixie understand
me those Armenians don't give a [ __ ]
they're not like these okey-doke
[ __ ] you hang around at
Starbucks don't do anything for you yeah
okay these [ __ ] got caught me
yes I got a van we had to bury somebody
last night
I'll clean the DNA out then I come over
the [ __ ] picture if you don't have an
Armenian friend and a true friend shoot
yourself in the [ __ ] head
we're all from me I'm okay a puffin like
it's [ __ ] the last day of life I
joined in the standing then join my
brother I used to be a miserable little
[ __ ] my [ __ ] twenties and for a
while again but it gave me nothing
this is what it's all about let the Sun
hit your face and the happiness of God's
[ __ ] hand comes in
not we'll do this one that'll be the
push that's the [ __ ] tighten it's got
some kick to it just not done
I'm having Chinese people can kick
let's go bald is pure cush and I gotta
go to do [ __ ] now that you do [ __ ]
you don't have a good [ __ ] time with
your family today cuz that's what it's
all about [ __ ] it's your family
maybe put the [ __ ] burger on the
grill and just sitting back and going
you know what
how much do I [ __ ] love you
and I said it's [ __ ] we're blessed
that we could do this together
just doesn't that's a little [ __ ]
family this is us this is just about us
right now
so many people that say this
and we get together once a day the smoke
the [ __ ] boat
these [ __ ] wanna be s that's
how that's how kind of [ __ ] game
there's the others man we're getting
together doing [ __ ] hits ass
mushrooms [ __ ] bong it's like family
and they were almost osmosis I'm so
stoned right now stop number I'm like a
Gentile at Starbucks after I get to
drink some coffee just like talking I'll
of Biafra sweaters [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] you're talking about
I was at the farmers market for four
minutes this morning my blood pressure
was 160 over 100 seeing these people 160
everyone I don't dance Sunday mom is my
mom I pick up a little [ __ ] fish a
little coconut milk
I got a nice salmon my shrimp down there
and a bear okay before the rest of these
[ __ ] people
does you Keeney's look beautiful clarity
[ __ ] zucchinis around they times
ahead damn the [ __ ] wrong with bleep I
don't need zucchini that's just the way
it is and that's it I'm talking to the
[ __ ] girl tomorrow night I'm at the
Roxy theater singing kill it and the
name was are you kidding me or what I'm
live of them go to ten [ __ ] minutes
and then I'm gonna sing killing in the
name of my [ __ ] Rage Against the
Machine can I say [ __ ] no but I can't do
a lot of the things either but you gotta
give them a shot from time to time I'm
saying take a chance Columbus did
[ __ ]
it's Sunday smoke your weed go hang out
with your families write your [ __ ]
goals now and get ready for [ __ ]
tremendous week I know these people you
dealing like they're gonna be thinking
of my way with it then we're gonna go to
shore and karaoke in the car what the
[ __ ] are you talking about that's me you
can't sees people asleep most of my
biggest [ __ ] down most of my biggest
[ __ ] properties little people are
[ __ ] around on the weekend there and
they believe they announce mm you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
they've taken about [ __ ] grilled
cheese sandwiches meanwhile guys like
you want us thinking about a [ __ ]
emblem get the [ __ ]
anyway I love you [ __ ] have a
great day see you tonight at 7 o'clock
on the Church of what's happening now
and always remember [ __ ] you I won't do
what you tell me you understand me
that's it [ __ ] you I won't do what you
tell me that's my motto since I was
[ __ ] 5 PS 166 89 speed off amps at
that Avenue that was the state apartment
not because I was [ __ ] on it I
couldn't speak English I don't know what
the [ __ ] these people saying anyway
anyway tonight 7 o'clock I'm stoned that
girl's gonna kick the weak walls on a
[ __ ] bang all right I love you
[ __ ] have a phenomenal day or a
bowl of being a little